mutter neuen film dorf ist
beide schauspielerinnen gehen auf ihre
art sehr entspannt mit dem älterwerden
um
und dennoch werden sie laufend von der
presse darauf angesprochen ein fluch
meint diese frau
bascha mika stößt eine debatte an in der
sie an klagt die gesellschaft schiebt
den frauen den schwarzen peter zu am
großen gesellschaftsspiel des
älterwerdens
während sozusagen die
persönlichkeitsentwicklung bei den
männern mit einem großen plus zeichen
versehen wird wird die entwicklung des
älterwerdens bei frauen mit einem ganz
großen - zeichen versehen
bascha mika beschreibt worauf wir uns
alles langen geeinigt haben frauen
werden über ihren körper definiert
jung und fruchtbar muss der seien in dem
ideal zu entsprechen
doch gerade der körper ist es der zuerst
spürbar
so steht am ende die abwertung der frau
und das demütigende gefühl ich werde
unsichtbar
ich verschwinde der verschwinde
flugschrift uns ja nicht als einzelne da
trifft er uns auch und kränkt und tut
weh aber vor allen dingen ist es ja ein
gesellschaftlicher mechanismus der uns
als gruppe trifft nur darüber wissen wir
ganz ähnlich darüber reden wir auch
nicht sondern wir schämen uns für unser
älterwerden bei die bilder von außen uns
suggerieren
sobald du älter wirst bist du weniger
wert bist du nicht mehr attraktiv bist
du nicht mehr erotisch bist du nicht
mehr begehrenswert aber eben du
verlierst auch ein ganzes stück eines
sozialen status
gegen diese abwertung müssten frauen
kämpfen neue sehgewohnheiten schaffen
frauen nicht aus der öffentlichen bild
welt vertreiben nur weil sie 40 sind 50
oder 60 in england klagte eine
moderatorin der bbc gegen ihre
verbannung vom bildschirm wegen ihrer
falten altersdiskriminierung botox
wollte sie sich nicht verordnen lassen
sie gewann vor gericht wenn ich über
jahre eine fernsehfrau begleiten kann
mit ihrem älter werden dann habe ich
natürlich da auch ein vorbild und
natürlich ist es dann so dass ich denke
ach die ist jetzt ich bin jetzt älter
geworden die ist jetzt auch älter
geworden deren falten sind doch ganz
okay dann können ja meine falten auch
okay sein also der findet so eine
wechselwirkung statt
wenn aber die frauen einfach nicht mehr
auftauchen ab einem bestimmten alter hat
natürlich auch die zuschauerin in der
hinsicht keine ansprechpartnerin frauen
über 40 bekommen wenig film und
fernsehen
das wundert viele schauspielerinnen die
angst bleibt immer das sagt ein wenn
jemand wenn man ein kind kriegt die
angst kriegt man einfach gratis dazu
wenn eine nicht gerade größer heißt
bleiben meist ähnliche kleinere
eindimensionale rollfeld in dem neuen
sind das nicht dafür gibt es ein wort
mutter fach diesem wort haften eben auch
die ganzen
begrifflichkeiten daran finde ich wofür
die frau in der werbung eben auch
missbraucht wird und was ich ihnen sehr
interessant finde das ist das das wort
mutter im vergleich zum gurt hält
absolut negativ konnotiert ist also an
bord mutter da klebt kleben so begriffe
dran wie uns ex sie übergewicht
depressionen und der held hat sowieso
schon mal keine familie und reißt sich
um sich und trägt die welt in sich und
reitet und die prärie gucken dem
sonnenuntergang entgegen so oft in
geschlechterfragen aus skandinavien
die dänische polizei wurden zum beispiel
bietet viel reichhaltiger frauen
auch jenseits der 40 doch auch im
deutschsprachigen raum hat sich einiges
getan
die schauspielerin friederike wagner
gehört zum ensemble des schauspielhauses
zürich und erlebt dort einen anderen
frischen blick aufs alter und auf die
schlechter fahren
rollen die zwar auf dem papier
vielleicht 25 sind besetzt war mit einer
48 jährigen und also man geht viel
spielerischer mit dem alter um und mit
den geschlechtern also es passiert auch
viel öfter dass frauen männer
rollenspielen und männer frauen rollen
spielen
nun bekommt auch die werbeindustrie
etwas nachhelfen bilder schöner starker
frauen über 50 lanciert von facebook
chefin sheryl sandberg und der
fotoagentur getty images die verbreitung
solcher bilder an der werbung könnte
auch männern etwas bringen
männer würden genauso profitieren war
ist inzwischen so läuft dass auch männer
zunehmend unter druck geraten wenn sie
älter werden
das ist längst noch nicht so ausgeprägt
wie bei frauen
aber bei jungen männern sieht man die
tendenz schon sehr deutlich dass sie
auch nicht mehr wie früher glauben sie
könnten irgendwie aussehen und sich
irgendwie anziehen und irgendeinen
körper haben und würden dann trotzdem
noch als attraktiv gelten
männer und frauen gemeinsam gegen den
jugendwahn
bascha mika möchte eine revolution
anzetteln
doch es ist schon viel erreicht wenn wir
uns der bilder bewusst werden wie unsere
wahrnehmung prägen auch die vom
älterwerden